today's eclipse might become the most
photographed event in history but taking
the perfect picture takes lots of
preparation we ask new york-based
photographer an amateur astronomer that
Stan Honda about some tricks of the
trade
here's his advice on how to capture the
eclipse and why you may not Tony Meranti
a member of our crew want to photograph
it with your smartphone don't do it
my name is Stan Honda I photographed a
lot of night sky landscapes and
astronomical events like eclipses the
one total eclipse that I photographed
was in a place called Svalbard which is
an archipelago of islands pretty far
north of Norway but it was a spectacular
clip so it's something that I'll never
forget I was surprised at how fast once
the moon covered up face beside it was
like someone had turned the light off
target me it's just a matter of trying
to adjust the camera to the changing
light conditions one thing I tell people
who ask how to photograph an eclipse
what kind of settings they should use is
mainly to look at the eclipse because
it's something that you'll never ever
forget I probably spend a little bit too
much time adjusting my camera
for the partial phase of eclipse you
definitely need the protective solar
glasses and you need a good approved
filter for your camera lens I think if
people have a digital SLR or the newer
mirrorless cameras I which is just
bringing one camera and one lens because
you won't be able to change lenses and
just decide on the kind of picture that
you want and when you're shooting the
Eclipse since your shutter speed might
feel pretty slow you definitely need you
have the camera on a tripod to have it
steady the Sun in the summer is quite
high in the sky and so if you want the
Sun and some of the landscape then
you'll need a pre wide-angle lens
as the Eclipse begins as the moon starts
to take a bite out of the Sun or move
over the face of the Sun that's one
exposure through and you have to have
the filter and then right at totality
you have to take the filter off the
front of the camera lens because it
blocks out so much of the light and it's
it's a much longer exposure during
totality because you're photographing
not any part of the sun's face but the
corona which is the outer atmosphere and
it's much much dimmer than the face of
the Sun
I'm sure a lot of people want to take
pictures of the clips with their
smartphones and the sky will turn very
black it'll be like night things like
smartphones tend to overexpose the
pictures you can try to adjust the
manual settings in the phone itself but
that might involve a lot of time and
looking at a lot of menus and the
eclipse is happening as you're trying to
do this the more than you see these
clips with your eyes you'll have this
memory that you'll you'll you'll never
forget it and the pictures may or may
not be good but I think your memory will
be the best thing that you'll have for
the rest of your lives
[Music]
you
[Music]